Instead, it is that both macro-level and micro-level peacebuilding are needed
to make peace sustainable,
and local nongovernmental organizations,
local authorities and civil society representatives
should be the main actors in the bottom-up process.
So of course, there are obstacles.
Local actors often lack the funding
and sometimes the logistical means and the technical capacity
to implement effective, local peacebuilding programs.
So international actors should expand their funding and support
for local conflict resolution.
As for Congo, what can be done?
After two decades of conflict and the deaths of millions,
it's clear that we need to change our approach.
Based on my field research,
I believe that international and Congolese actors
should pay more attention to the resolution of land conflict
and the promotion of inter-community reconciliation.
So for instance, in the province of the Kivus,
the Life and Peace Institute and its Congolese partners
have set up inter-community forums
to discuss the specifics of local conflicts over land,
and these forums have found solutions to help manage the violence.
That's the kind of program that is sorely needed
throughout eastern Congo.
It's with programs like this
that we can help people like Isabelle and her husband.
So these will not be magic wands,
but because they take into account deeply rooted causes of the violence,
they could definitely be game-changers.
Thank you.
(Applause)